Uh, hello.
What's up, what's up? What what's your
real name, man? Cuz you keep coming up
here changing names.
>> Ramadan has started. Ramadan I just put
on there cuz it's the first day of
Ramadan and put Ramadan 2026.
Uh. Thank you for spending uh Ramadan
with us. Yeah.
Hey, how how do you know it's the first
day of Ramadan because the Muslims are
split as to when the first day is?
>> Yeah, in Egypt they say Ramadan
Guys, guys, he's a Quran only. I'm Quran
only. I'm a Muslim. So how does he
really know?
But I know from from the lunar calendar.
From the lunar calendar. You can prove
it from the Quran. I know, but the
Muslims have the same lunar calendar and
they split on which day Ramadan is
first.
>> Cuz they cuz they do it from like what
it says in Saudi Arabia specifically.
They don't go by what it says for where
they actually live. You know what I
mean?
They go by
they go by sighting the moon.
>> Yeah. So if the scholars in Saudi Arabia
sight the moon on one day, then that's
when then same in Egypt. They have
Yeah, definitely. Well, they take
authority from outside the Quran. I'm
not sure exactly like how they do it.
>> you know that Ramadan starts today then?
How do you know? Yeah, how how do you
know as a Quran only follow people who
don't follow the Quran? We don't say
that. We go by by the ninth month of the
lunar calendar.
Yeah, but They didn't but there's no
calendar in the Quran though. So how do
you know?
>> lunar calendar. We go by the lunar
calendar.
>> Yeah, but but they're going by the lunar
calendar, too. And they're
>> I don't know how they did it. Well, I
don't I don't know how they did it, but
>> we know you didn't deviate though?
That's what we want to know.
>> 2 2189.
So 2189 is your calendar? No, no, no. So
which day? Tomorrow or day after?
In in in 2189 when it says, hold on.
Yeah, we know what it says. It doesn't
tell you what date in 2026 to fast. And
if you don't fast the first day
properly, you know, if you break the
fast on the first day, you're sinful.
Well, God's not going to punish me for
being one day off.
God's not going to punish me for being
one day off. How do you know? No, wait.
How do you know?
How do you know God's not going to
punish you? God is the most merciful. We
go by the merciful that I'm given.
>> But he's also he's also a muntaqim. He's
also the most vengeful. How do you know
which one He's going to be merciful
today, merciful tomorrow. How do you
know? Well, he's he's
No, no, no, no, no, no, shirk is
unforgivable sin. We're just We're just
We're just playing with you just to show
the
reality of Quran only Muslim is Well, we
have We also appeal to the authority of
the messenger of the covenant, Dr.
Rashad Khalifa. David Wood, have you
ever heard about Rashad Khalifa?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah, he got killed, didn't he? For him.
Yeah, he he he got martyred. He He was
blessed with with martyrdom just like
previous messengers, right? And 2:87 it
says messengers were killed when God
kept sending them the the Jews that the
Bani Israel they were killing them.
Yeah, so he was expelled from Egypt. He
came to America and got killed. Uh
what religion was the person who killed
him just for everyone to know? She was a
Sunni. He was a Muslim a Muslim.
That's sad, man. Somebody Saudi Arabian
government, yeah.
So
Rashid Khalifa is a messenger after
Muhammad? Messenger, yeah. Muhammad's
the final prophet but not the final
messenger. Got you. Got
You're so gone, man. I'm sorry. I'm
[laughter]
How? How?
Hold on. See, even with your face up
there and everything, man. Yeah, you're
afraid that's going to happen to you
too, huh? Pray for me. Pray for me. Pray
for me. Yeah, we we will pray for you.
>> [laughter]
>> We will pray. Yeah, so
David Wood, yeah, what do you know about
Rashad Khalifa? We don't care about
Rashad Khalifa. We care about the We
care about how Muhammad's demon
possessed, man. Oh, yeah. Okay, so well,
you know what's funny? Yeah, the I think
you guys mentioned this. The Quran says
that the the disbelievers they say that
the prophet was bewitched, right? And
the people who wrote the Hadith says
that he was bewitched.
>> [laughter]
>> Disbelievers.
You know, it was Aisha, right? You think
Aisha is an unbeliever then cuz her
narrator No, he doesn't even probably
believe Let me tell you something,
right? I want the I want the Muslims to
hear this, too. Talk to them. Yeah, if
Aisha
>> [laughter]
>> Hold on. Hold on. Yeah, let me give you
big stream. Hold on. Let me Let me
expand you, man. Talk to them. Oh, man.
If Aisha actually said all that
nonsense, she is going to hell, no
doubt.
>> Woah. That's right. That's true. Guess
what? The the Noah's wife and Lot's wife
uh uh they were both disbelievers. So,
just cuz you're the wife of the prophet
doesn't mean anything. Boom.
So, Aisha's not your mother? You heard
it here, everyone. Well, the thing is
like my my literal mother, right? She
like if she's a disbeliever, she's still
my mother, right? So, is she your
spiritual mother?
>> but but the but the Quran says
Muhammad's wives are the mothers of the
believers? Yeah. But even like if if if
my mom if she's if she's a polytheist,
let's say she's a Hindu or something,
she's still my mother but but not a not
a believer, you know what I mean?
>> So, Aisha's your mother or not? Yeah,
but even if she's Yeah, so but even he's
pointing out even if she's not a
believer
Yeah, I don't think she said that stuff
though. I don't I don't believe she said
that stuff, but I'm just saying if.
Mhm. So, if she said it, she's still
your mother but she's a very bad mother
going to hell.
You you believe that? You believe in him
having a a wife named Aisha?
Um the Quran doesn't say, but like if if
he had a wife named Aisha who walked and
and and breathed, right? I got no
problem with that. So, you you don't you
don't know who his wives were.
You just know he had wives. Yeah, yeah,
the Quran says he had wives, right? And
okay, for sure. Yeah, that's very
interesting, man. Mhm. So, so how you
said that chapter 2 verse 189 tells you
which
how to find the day of Ramadan to fast?
>> Well, it says they say yes alunakum I'll
read it in English. It's In English says
they ask you, prophet, about the phases
of the moon. Say they are meant for
people to determine time and and
pilgrimage.
Okay.
>> How does that help you know when the
first day of Ramadan is? So, what we
were saying was that all the Muslims are
using the lunar calendar. In Egypt, they
use the lunar calendar. Saudi Arabia
uses lunar calendar.
They both have They both have different
days for when Ramadan starts. There's
like a a war with their scholars.
>> They're both following the same verse
you're doing and they came up with
different days. Uh-huh. So, how do we
know that you have the right day? That's
what we want Well, the thing is cuz I I
appeal to the authority of the messenger
of the covenant. But he didn't tell you
what the first day of Ramadan is. No, he
tells us exactly. I mean, he tells us
how to calculate properly. But they are
going by the calculations, too. So, we
want to know how do you know how do you
know you're the right one?
I don't know exactly how they end up
differently, but I think um they go by
like the Saudi Arabian like the Saudi
Arabian sightings and they just go off
let's say Saudi Arabia their sightings
is this. So, everybody start off this
day. But no, you got to go by your own
sightings for your But don't you don't
find it weird that your religion tells
you to fast according to something in
the sky?
Something in the sky according to the
moon sightings? Yeah. I'm going to guess
that because you know
people who worship the sun and the moon,
they go by what they want to tell them
to do down here. You don't think that's
weird?
No. You don't think that's weird? No. We
go by the moon sightings.
>> you don't think that your life being run
by the moon is a bit pagan?
My life being My life is not run by the
moon. It tells you when to fast we're
supposed to fast. Well, who controls the
moon? God, right? And obviously we might
differ on who that God who that God is,
but we know it's the the Lord of the
universe. But a God doesn't tell me to
go by what the sun's doing to do some to
worship him. But I can pray to him past
anytime. Well, lunar calendar. Just like
when God talks about the months, right?
Uh-huh. It goes to the lunar calendar.
It might not say September, October,
November, December, but it's still
>> So, so you're okay with not knowing when
Ramadan really starts? I know look, if
I'm a if I'm a day off, day off is
nothing. I'm I'm going to But you're
just saying you're a day off because
like you're lining it up with what like
Saudi Arabia We go by the lunar
calendar. How do you know that they're
not like a month off? How do you know
they're like a month off? You don't
know. But if if they were so wrong about
Muhammad because of the teachings of
Muhammad, if they were so wrong about
that, how do you know they're not like
cuz you're saying okay, they could be a
day off or something. How do you know
they're like a month or or 6 months off?
How do you know? Well, we go by the
lunar calendar. And I go You've been
saying that, but they're all going by
the lunar calendar. You do know you do
know that it's obligatory fasting. It's
not a day off like it's voluntary. I
know all about it. It's sinful if you
don't fast this the right day.
And you have to make it up if you you
know if you if you don't make it up you
have to make it up. We're in the day. It
depends on what depends on which Quran
you read you got to You got to make an
update.
So there's yeah, there's there's 30
different Qurans, right? They're they're
not Oh, it's brother, it's Quran.
It's just different recitations. No,
that's that's all BS. Oh, okay. So
what's the real Quran then?
>> The Hafs. The Hafs is the closest one to
what the Prophet Muhammad
>> How do you know that? The code 19.
Through code 19.
How do you How do you know that? The
code 19, bro.
>> 19 The code 19 only works for
>> The code. Oh. So the code 19, it's a
supernatural coding system in the Quran
that proves that it's from God. So who
told you that? Your Quran only? Does the
Quran say anything about the number 19?
>> Uh yeah, in chapter 74:30-31,
it says
over it is 19. You know, it's talking
about hell. That verse is talking about
hell. Keep Keep reading. It says we have
made their number. So we have made their
number, which is 19, has five specific
functions. One of them is um is showing
to people that that the Quran is from
God or showing that
>> hold on. But but wait wait wait. So So
>> The verse is talking about how many
>> Wait. So did that
only work in Hafs? Does the 19 only work
in Hafs?
Uh yeah, Hafs is the closest. You see
You still see like the patterns or like
the So you think
you think there's still room There's
still room for error. So are there some
error in Hafs? Uh no. I mean Well, look,
there there are He had extra verses in
Surah Nine. Exactly. He No, he he didn't
add anything. Are you talking about
Rashad Khalifa? No, not
not Khalifa. We're talking about Hafs.
Hafs has the Hafs has the two verses
that Khalifa took away. Yeah. Yeah,
let's let's talk about it. So yeah,
chapter 9:128, if you read it in the
Arabic, the messenger is called often
rahim, right? And this is what God is
called in eight different verses. All
right. This is a good argument. Yeah,
this is a good argument for you guys to
use against the Muslims.
Yeah, we we we we we do that, but
doesn't it But doesn't that make he
calls himself a submitter. The
That That So we we get you, and that
that theologically is messed up.
However, the question is this: Hafs has
those two verses there. I know.
Rashad Khalifa takes them out. Yeah, cuz
they were they were part of the the
Right. So Hafs has So, Hafs is messed up
his his
Quran is messed up, right?
>> Mhm.
But without without without those two
verses you the structure is fully proven
that it's from God cuz for me it's a
huge problem.
>> So, then the Hafs version can't be true
then because it cuz it has those two
verses. That knocks out 19. And we also
use the oldest manuscripts as well. We
have the Birmingham Birmingham I don't
think I don't think it helps you.
That's like 54 verses. That doesn't help
you.
>> It's not enough verses. Birmingham? Show
any problem.
So, you follow the point. You're saying
that Hafs is the closest. I said, "What
do you mean by closest? Is there still
room for error?" You said, "No, there's
no error." But then I spun out that the
last two chapter nine Well, minus those.
Minus those.
>> [laughter]
>> Why is that the Hey, that's going to go
in the red book. I don't know
>> [laughter]
>> You minus from your book.
I'm not I'm not taking them out. I'm not
taking them out.
You need to submit it to the red book. I
submitted it to the red book. Number 28,
the messenger is called Ra'uf Raheem.
This is one of God's names in the Quran.
You use it against the Muslims. Yeah,
that's the problem. God's problem. That
means you're against the Muslims. You're
against the Muslims. Yeah, you use it
against We're using it against the
submitters, too. Against the submitters?
Yeah. But we don't believe in those
verses. They're never part of the
revelation. So, then you have a
corrupted Quran. It's not corrupted. The
Quran is preserved in in the master
tablet. But obviously, the physical
handheld Quran can easily be corrupted.
Like if I add two pages to the Bible You
just You just said the Quran's
corrupted.
>> No, no. Not the No, the Quran's
preserved in the master tablet, but a
physical
>> Uh-huh. The Quran we have here on this
earth The The handheld The handheld
Quran Yeah.
Just the Just the mushaf Just paper ink
and paper.
>> get the point. The handheld Quran, is it
corrupted?
The handheld It is. It's just ink and
paper. But the But the Quran that gets
corrupted
>> I know it's ink I know it's ink and
paper. I can see it. Is it corrupted or
not? Check Check this out. Are you going
to show us a Quran? No, we we've never
seen a Quran before.
You
You better not rip the Quran. We We
>> [laughter]
>> All right. If If you have the last two
verses of chapter nine, will you rip
them out? Yeah, take them out. Take them
out. The last two verses are not part of
the revelation. If you have the last two
verses of chapter 9 in your Quran, will
you rip those? Huh? I'll just take them
out. Yo, just All right, we need to show
we need to see you ripping them in front
in front of David Wood. Yeah, go on
then.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> If you have the last two verses in
chapter 9, you have to rip them in front
of David Wood.
>> then you'll have it perfect.
Uh chapter 9
Don't just rip just be aware we're going
to dox you after.
>> [laughter]
>> I came out. I didn't use my name out
intentionally.
>> I
>> [laughter]
>> I hey, I got I got a guy. Are you going
to put your face on there? I got a guy.
Yeah, Malik. Who did it? Malik did Who
did it?
>> [laughter]
>> Yes.
What did he say? If you're ripping
chapter 9, say say you're ripping it.
>> this is for Malik. It's [laughter] for
Malik. Look, this is not what I'm here
to do, but look This is not But it's
it's the Quran though. It's corrupt.
It's the Quran. All right, but I do want
to show you something as well. So so so
it's not the Quran, so you can take it
out.
>> Yeah, it's only in Arabic. It's okay.
You can rip it.
Yeah, it's not part of the revelation.
So what's it doing in there? I have the
English one in front of me though. I
have the English one in front of me.
Okay. Okay. Cool? You cool with you? I
don't know. Ask David. He's the he's the
master of it. Arabic only Arabic
matters.
Only Arabic um only Arabic.
I don't have it on me right now. Yeah,
it's it's okay, man. It's it's okay.
It's okay. So the point that we're
getting at is that even even as a as a
as a as submitter
who's distinct from the Muslims Yes. You
got you got
>> a sacred religion, bro. It's a satanic
religion. The Muslims worship Muhammad.
They worship Bukhari. They worship
Hadith. They worship scholars. They
worship They do. They do. All right. And
and so here's the issue is that so you
have you have your Quran from Rashad
Khalifa who they
who they who they unalived and got rid
of. Hold on. Let me get this guy out of
here, man. It's like Jesus. Jesus got
crucified for the Jews who wanted to
kill him, right? Yeah, so
I'm the the Quraysh who wanted to kill
him. So, you have So, with your Quran,
you your Quran has verses that were
taken out.
And without these with with these verses
in there, the code 19 doesn't work, does
it? Well, not only that, but it also it
also makes Muhammad God, basically. And
it And it makes Muhammad God. So, so
number one, so with these uh with with
the entire other world of Muslims
outside of the submitters, Mhm. they
have these corrupted Qurans
that have
>> No, sorry, over over 30 versions. Yeah,
all of them have these verses. I know.
Yeah. And so, all of these verses make
Muhammad I think there's over 30
versions of the Quran. Yeah, but They're
not recitations. They were called Hafs.
And all of these versions make Muhammad
God, correct? Well, they all have those
two verses, yeah. So, they're not
accidents. They're not
That's It's it's intentional. Also,
isn't it convenient?
Hold on. Hold on, but isn't it
It's it's not it's not just accidents.
No, it's not just accidents, but isn't
it convenient that the only chapter in
the whole entire Quran that's missing
the that's missing God's signature is
chapter nine? God didn't sign off on it
intentionally. Yeah, do you know why
that is?
Yeah, the reason why that is the reason
why that is cuz they didn't know they
didn't know if chapter eight was ending
at chapter eight or was beginning at
chapter nine. They didn't know. So, I
shouldn't really say that that's the
best explanation at the the the early
companions of the Prophet Muhammad.
That's what the Sunni's say. Yeah,
that's what the Sunni's say. That they
that that the companions didn't know
when they were compiling the Quran, they
didn't know whether to separate That's
what the Sunni's say. Yeah, that's what
the Sunni's say. That they that that
that the companions didn't know when
they were compiling the Quran, they
didn't know whether to separate chapter
eight like they didn't know whether
there's a part of it or not. So stupid.
No, no, no, that's So, what's the reason
then? What's the reason? That's what
that's what the Sunni scholars say.
According to Yeah, I know. So, yeah, God
he flagged a chapter nine first because
it was the only chapter that was going
to be tampered with
in terms of those two verses. So, you're
saying you're saying chapter nine is
tampered with? With those two verses,
but now hold on, it's purify now. It's
purified.
Who purified it? Wait, who? Khalifa. No,
to the messenger of the covenant. Oh,
wow. So what do you guys think about the
chapter 9 thing? Just really just really
quick, how do how do you know that he
was right for taking those verses out?
Where in the Where in the Quran does it
say that those verses don't belong?
Well, for one, in chapter 6 12 and
chapter 6 54, God says that mercy is his
attribute. It's not Muhammad's
attribute. How do you know that? How do
you know it's not his It says that he's
merciful in the verse. How do you know?
So the Quran is saying that Muhammad
does have the attribute of mercy. No,
9128. No, that's not God's revelation.
Look, I would The The reason I I can't
Yeah, based on what is my question My
question is based on what? Based Where
does the Quran tell you that 9128 and
129 are not revelation of Allah?
The The The messenger did and we we have
proof for that because Quran 19 was up
to two
You're going outside of the Quran. No,
no, hold on. Okay, well So you're So
you're saying again Now Now you're Now
you're
Hold on. Inside Inside the Quran. Yeah,
inside inside. So Okay, so where Yeah,
where in the Quran does it tell you that
9120 and I know J Dizzle got to go
pretty soon today but you know, we're
going to We're going to wrap up with
this. Can I talk to you before
Nope. Nope. Nope.
Yeah, hey, you got to get through AB
first.
>> [laughter]
>> Yo, Ramadan 2026. If you If you actually
want to If there's something you want to
discuss with me and so on, let me let me
know what you want to talk about. We'll
set up a live stream on it. Of course.
Awesome. So, in the Quran and now and
and I'll let you answer and I won't I
won't fight you back on this cuz we got
to end this. Okay, but Just Just five
more Just a few more minutes. Just a few
more minutes. Sure. So, in the Quran In
the Quran, where does it tell you that
9128 and 29 are not revelation of Allah?
That they are
uh verses that don't belong.
>> Yeah, so judging by the context of 9128
in the Quran, uh the Prophet Muhammad,
he was commanded to say that he has he
has no power to to benefit himself or
anybody else. So this is Raheem that
means that he has the power because it
says 912 most merciful most kind that's
what Raheem is most merciful most kind
to the believers. It doesn't say to the
believers of his time. So that that
would mean that Muhammad is still
benefiting me or people today.
It's not true. I won't fight you on that
cuz I got to end it. I do have rebuttals
but I
like what you did there. Yeah. But
what I want to show you though what I
want to show you is
>> I don't I don't got time for you to show
me that in the sun. It's not it's not
for you I'm just saying to answer one of
your questions for it was for Jane and
Doc.
What what question? So like when you say
also that the hand held Quran is
corrupted. Well let me ask you this if I
take an Arabic Quran or Arabic Bible and
I have an one extra page to it is the is
the corrupted now or is it just the
physical text that's corrupted? I was
asking you. That's what we wanted to
know cuz you were the one saying it's
the it's the the one that's the closest
closest to Muhammad's Quran. Yeah so
let's say if I take
this piece of paper right and then I I
add it into the Quran right? It's same
size same text same everything. Is the
Quran corrupted now or is it just the
physical text? Same same with the Well
it is it says it's a verse with a number
and so the Quran at the end of it. So
Muslims are saying to us this is
preserved. So I'm asking you what's your
evidence? Which one ask them which one.
Yeah Quran 19 is our evidence but for
that Which which Quran is preserved is
the question. It's the the most closest
one. We have we have access to the Quran
of the master tablet through Quran 19.
Okay. It's the it's not exactly correct.
It's the it's it's the closest through
like
But but not exactly right? It's exactly
as the tablets in heaven right? What I
what I want to do you remember you
remember Abdullah the the submitter
right? No forget it brother answer the
question Hassan. Slow down and answer
the question.
Is is is does Hafs match the preserved
tablet of the Quran in heaven? Without
without the two verses and even
No no stop saying without.
Hafs as it is does it match the Quran in
heaven?
Yeah, through through court 19, yeah.
Okay. Wait, wait. Without without the
verses that are in it, though.
It's the Quran by the Hey, focus, man.
Oh, sorry. Someone Someone's welcome.
It's okay. I got to wrap it up. All
right. Thanks for your time. Hey, look.
David is going to have you on, bro.
David will have you on. Hey. He'll He'll
let you cook all the Sunnis, man. Trust
me. He He just destroyed Islam. Yeah.
Yeah, he doesn't believe it. He says
Islam is a satanic religion.
Yeah, he does. He says that. He's got a
point there. He's got a point. He's got
a He's got a huge point.
>> You do have a point.